I start to notice weird things happening
with my kids I said um give me a kiss
goodnight and he won't know you need to
ask my consent
I was like
do I
said yeah at school they say you've got
to ask consent and I said I'm your dad
and he said
yeah but you still have trust consent I
mean okay we're gonna have a little
lesson on consent here how do people who
are trying to raise awareness of certain
issues have a conversation and what is
the best way to approach it you know if
you give ground to sort of things like
non-binary and stuff like that if you
don't just ridicule it immediately 10
years down the line it's going to be you
will have given the ground and we'll be
dealing with something else in the Bible
it says love your enemies I because I
think just as a philosophical and
emotional exercise it is absolutely
where your brain should be how can we
find a love for them because if I can
love them then I can listen to them I
see the same tactics now starting to be
used and that I think should Warriors
actually well I couldn't agree with you
more because there's a there's an
appetite for Revenge yes when those
tactics are used
thank you
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our returning guest today is an
actor presenter politician he's a man of
many times Lawrence folks welcome back
hi guys how are you doing it's been a
while it has been a while and you've
been up to quite a lot in the time that
we haven't spoken so the first time we
spoke you were an actor
oh yeah you were I you you were my um I
broke my translation virginity with you
you did you did I we had nothing to do
with that just for the record you did it
all by yourself Lawrence I know um and
then we spoke to you after all of after
you went on question time and Etc and
since that time as I said you you've
stood for London mayor you're now
presenting GB news you've started the
bad law project and the reclaim party so
you've been up to quite a lot I have
indeed it's been it's been a pretty busy
time and it seems to get busier and
busier all the time as well but it's um
it's good I think it's a I think it's I
was thinking the other day whether I
missed acting which I sort of do because
it's my heart and soul and I love it but
um I was also thinking what happened
could I go on a film set anymore would
people run screaming away probably not
the Sparks and the chippies in your
average people but the closer you get to
the camera how much It Go like no
fascist run so um yeah it's certainly
been a quite a substantial change yeah
well once you get involved in politics
these things inevitably happen don't
they yeah but I didn't I didn't really
want to be involved in politics I want
to be involved in culture so
um the politics side of it I'm less
interested in oh you are yeah because I
mean you stood from for London May and
you just started a party it's difficult
it's kind of hard to well no but I think
you know the Stan even on the main thing
was I was so I'm still so fed up with
the way City Khan treats people and I'm
you know I'm fed up with the way a lot
of people are treated you know the
Oxford thing I was there the other day
um at the March when they surveyed all
their local residences to whether they
wanted their sort of 15-minute City and
being able to travel 100 times a year 90
of them said no we don't they said well
we're putting it in any way so I was you
know my my ticket for the London mayor
with my PR people at the time I said I'm
gonna stand for under mayor and then
you're gonna get two percent I went no
I'm not it's locked down
get ready for power I got 1.9 percent
you're fired yeah but Lawrence if you're
interested in culture then why have you
gone down the political route
because you do have to have that threat
at the end of the day I mean I don't
think it is ever going to be a
substantial threat but you've got to
have you've got to go you can't be all
barking no bite but actually the biggest
changes that we've managed to achieve
have been cultural and on the grounds of
activism stuff you know the Hampshire
police thing with the with the uh pride
flag swastika which got me as Neil
Oliver described it plus like a uh us
like a vcn bar transform and
anti-semitic at the same time so
um but we did get the chief Constable of
Hampshire police removed and actually
she she drops off her uniform this
morning that was her last day in office
and let's go into that so the people who
don't know what actually happened around
that story so I posted the meme that
have been I mean apparently I've been
around for a while but I hadn't seen it
of during pride month of the four uh
Progressive Pride Flags I think it's
even got even more Progressive now
there's a ring there's a circle in it
it's even more migraine inducing which
happens to form the shape of swastika as
the pot making the point that there is
only one flag one cannot criticize and
that is the holy pride flag and um I did
it because I thought I bet you this will
get me in trouble
for criticizing the prime fact and you
know adding in the fact that it was you
know you can also criticize the the only
other fact that it was illegal to
criticize I believe was the uh or deface
in any way was the Nazi [__] so I thought
stubble bubble and Truth formula social
media went mental and I had to remove it
for hateful content content but what
then happened is someone else shared on
their Facebook yes you getting in
trouble is very interesting but let's be
fair it's not a unique inside all about
me yeah so a guy called Darren Brady who
was their ex-green jacket uh posted and
he posted it on Facebook and just went
what are your thoughts so he wasn't
saying he was actually just trying to
get a debate started anyway he got
visited by the police on a Sunday
morning three of them came in knocking
on his door on you know he lives on a
quiet Road and it's you know why is
three people you know neighbors looking
out curtain twitching and um he got
visited by the coppers he said I'm you
know I'm not available to talk now and
then called the bad door project and we
went down with the ever tactful Harry
Miller and myself went down with Alex to
film them the police as they rearranged
the appointment and the police being the
police weren't expecting that and um
instead of de-escalating they they
upscaled so we ended up I think with
about 11 coppers by that time and um
Darren was arrested Harry was arrested
um I was walking around going I was the
one that do it in the first place arrest
me but they refused to arrest me and um
at the end of the day it made it went a
bit mental around the internet and it
cost the chief Constable her job do you
know what when I was watching it my my
initial thought was this is the weirdest
version of Beatles about I've ever seen
in my life imagine police turning up
somewhere then Lauren's Fox comes in
well that's what we did we literally
walked out of the kitchen and we're like
I mean how are you going straight in
because yeah he's he's bug there is the
police and I think he's really correct
in that and you don't want political
police force not a good sign of where
Society is going if you've got political
police force so yeah but what was so
strange is they couldn't de-escalate it
they they all they did was they got it
more and more wound up and um yeah it it
wasn't good for them it was a bad day
for the police and it and it put on in
people's minds the fact that you know
are you dealing with an impartial
policeman who's pleasing that fear or
favor or are you dealing with a
political police force police is one set
of people different from another which
is what we've got in this country well
so I'm curious about the approach then
because changing the culture yeah uh I
mean I and there's been a lot of
conversation about the smaller parties
in the UK uh sort of right-of-center
parties like reform your party reclaim
there's others that you know they don't
all roll off the tongue as easily but
but the Heritage there's always
conversation about how they should come
together ukip whatever is left of that
whatever uh you know coming together and
orchestrating some sort of actual
Rebellion but you don't think that's
really the way to change anything well
my my thing is again you know in the
fact that I don't really like being
political I would much rather we return
to a semblance of a a solid left which
was a traditional left not a mad woke
left that we've got at the moment and a
sort of solid-ish right and so I would
always much rather put pressure on the
conservatives to be conservative than I
would Nick 600 votes or whatever you
know these little parties are going to
do which is to which is to put labor
government in which might be a problem
so I'm more interested in Project make
conservatives conservative again than I
am in maid Lawrence in charge of
anything because you know as my funder
said primary funders said uh when I ran
for London mayor he said no one would
want you in charge of the tube
so I think it's more you know culturally
you can you can create a bigger change
and also it's waking people up to stuff
you know because my my passion and
Harry's passion is pleasing my passion
is education because obviously I've got
two kids in school and I started to
notice weird things happening with my
kids so the first one was my eldest son
a few years ago I said
um give me a kiss goodnight or a hug
good night whatever and he went no you
need to ask my consent
I was like
do I said yeah it's cool they say you've
got to ask consent and I said I'm your
dad and he said yeah but you still have
to ask consent and I went okay we're
gonna have a little lesson on consent
here consent is don't touch a stranger's
private parts all right that's consent
don't touch invade someone's face in
that part I'm your father so anyway I
wrote to school and I said what's going
on here because he's obviously not
understood consent and they said well we
don't really get to the sexual part of
it until later and I said well you can
take it from me I've just taught both of
my children consent lesson one in about
five minutes
and then I noticed that um
you know it's like going okay well where
is this stuff coming from so it comes
out of relationships education classes
and pshe and stuff like that so I I got
some lesson plans from another school
and found out what was on it which is
privileged skin color privilege gender
ideology
um diversity and inclusion all of the
things that you just don't want kids
being taught at a young age when they're
confused as it is and so I thought we
gotta change that so we're going to do
that as well that's what we're it's our
next sort of cultural project which is
going to be called bad education we
decided to put bad in front of
everything I just feel it's a better
idea yeah so that being the case
although your children are in private
school yeah and I think and this is
anecdotally but it's far worse in
private school than it is in state
school because I've got for instance
children are in private schools and they
say exactly the same thing as you yeah I
think that the guilts well you know is
it true I was reading this the other day
they're all
um sort of revolutionary movements start
in the upper middle privilege middle
class you know and I think that's it
there's a lot of guilt in that school
and they you know there's a lot of they
do talks about how do I talk to Michael
about race and stuff like that and I'm
like don't have that
um chat because they're all obviously
these kids are all a multitude of
different ethnicities and you should go
how do I talk to my kid about the fact
that he's a [__] millionaire and he's
going to bump into a load of people that
aren't yeah in life so it's there's a
huge amount of guilt in private schools
and I also wonder whether you'd find you
know what the ratio of you know young
trans children would be in a city
poverty written schools as well I don't
would be as high as it is in Posh
schools and the problem is as well is
that they Infuse this ideology into the
curriculum whilst at the same time
ignoring what the school should actually
be there for which is to educate and
teach yeah well it also it leaks out of
it as well so you'll have pride month or
something like that but people won't
take the flags down so it's sort of it's
always there or Black History Month it's
always you know things remain and I
think it's really divisive and I don't
like it and as you say kids need to be
taught to be actually kids need to be
taught to be confident to speak their
minds that's the most important thing
you can give a child to do and um they
don't really need to be sort of
brainwashed into being good little
comrades which is essentially what they
what they what school can be about a lot
fortunately my kids have got me which is
probably quite a pain for them in a lot
of ways and a lot of the parents do part
like the Red Sea when I walk into school
except one black dad who goes
[Music]
well you joke about a Lawrence but
you've obviously since you first came on
our show you've attracted a lot of
negative attention and criticism and
column inches and you as your friend I
will say you put your foot in it
regularly yourself and sometimes like
opens when I go
really you had to say it like that like
how I mean are you okay like you I saw
you tweet something saying you know it's
the first time I've not been anxious for
a long time and and whatever yeah how
how has this been experienced the whole
thing has been for you as a person well
it's interesting I was thinking about
this and I was thinking about you and I
and you know when we used to walk around
Ruskin park with my dad do you remember
yeah it's like
in this desire to try and get a
conversation going you need different
sorts of activators and my activation
technique is to go bang that's what I
that's one of my ways of doing it on
social media and obviously in this
experience you've got more time to
express it but you you need to go look
I'm standing against you so strongly
and you've taken a different approach
which is to you know is to make sure you
know I read your thread this morning
about Putin's speech you take your time
to get it down there and you have your
sub stack and all this sort of stuff I'm
just using Twitter to go by the way guys
there's a wall here that you don't get
to cross and I will defend with with you
know not with sort of word violence if
you know what I mean so uh in terms of
am I okay
yeah no I am okay I'm like uh I had a I
had a difficult last year personally so
that was when I got um anxious and then
I got I've got on these um anti-anxiety
pills and I couldn't get off them so I
had to start running
and I managed to run myself out of
anti-anxiety you ran away from the
anxiety well I just it was the only
thing that could do it and who would
have thought that there was a an
anti-anxiety tool right there in front
of you and all you had to do was put on
a pair of trainers and it works a treat
well that that's good to hear but I'm
curious about because we're as we sit
here right now and this video will go
out uh later but we have we're in a
similar debate with Matt Walsh about how
do people who are trying to raise
awareness of certain issues uh have a
conversation and what is the best way to
approach it and him and you would say
you know you you come out and you you're
you're as as fighting and as strong as
you as you can be and you articulate the
truth without you know being overly nice
and whatever
um and as you say we we've we've done
that in the past ourselves but now we're
thinking about what what is the most
effective way to make an impact so I'm
open to be persuaded that sort of going
out and punching is is the right way
well but what what do you think is
achieved by doing that versus the the
approach that perhaps we look at well
it's a variety you what you need is a
broad Church in resistance to the
suppression of free expression so I
think there's room for both approaches
and I think actually you need basic
pages I think Matt Walsh and what he's
saying if you think about it you know if
you don't draw a line at some point and
his line he's very firmly chosen which
is that he would kill I mean I think he
almost said he'd kill someone who tried
to indoctrinate his child into gender
ideology like he's really hardcore about
it and that's his belief and he has
every right to it if you give ground
you'll get you know if you give ground
to sort of things like non-binary and
stuff like that if you don't just
ridicule it immediately you'll you're 10
years down the line it's going to be you
will have given the ground and we'll be
dealing with something else you know so
my position is hold the line over stuff
that really really matters to you now
yeah there's a debate to be had about
how one holds the line and you know but
I think actually it's quite a broad
church so you can have you can have the
more complex way of expressing it and
then you can have the you know he gave
me in one sentence this is what I feel
you know because you see how things are
starting to seep into our culture that
haven't been in our culture particularly
certainly like when I was in Oxford on
the weekend andrewville were there and I
haven't seen them I haven't seen them
any other protests that I've been to so
you know and we've got lots of other
debates coming in which has never been a
problem in the UK abortion's now
suddenly a big deal in the UK it's never
been a problem in the UK well we import
all this crap from America
but I suppose the reason I'm asking is
like
you are a hate figure to a lot of people
now great Tosh white bloke who doesn't
mind talking about anything and that's I
think that's why people like you as well
yeah you know you and I've said this
about you whether you and I have agreed
about stuff or not like of all the
people we've ever had on the show you
actually have probably as much cut
through as anybody with the ordinary
person in this country in my experience
like I remember in our old Studio that
you came to I used to park my car in
this underground garage run by a very uh
normal woman just you know she just runs
this garage that's all that she does
she's not an intellectual who's
interested in you know queer Theory or
whatever and with the moment she found
out we'd interviewed you that was it she
she thought I could park there anytime
for free she'd pay me to park that's
what it was like uh so you have that cut
through I think I guess what I'm I'm
just genuinely trying to explore this
with you is like if if you express
things in a way that makes it easy for
people to paint you is hateful which I
don't think you are no but people can
paint you that way then it sort of gives
ammunition to the antifas of the world I
suppose it would be an argument they
would do it anyway though you know like
I was painted as hateful the minute I
opened my mouth in question time so I
was called to be denounced the next
morning I was you know I was already a
figure and I knew that I was never going
to stop saying what needed what I felt
needed to be said so at the end of the
day when I walked down the streets I get
stopped frequently and people just say
thank you very much and weirdly
disproportionately by people of color
who go thank you for talking about us
like we're equals and we don't need to
be patronized by the white middle class
and I think in terms of the my hate
figure my hate figure of status is
assured by the fact that I'm straight
white and male and the fact that I'm
Posh doesn't help either and I don't
mind talking about race I don't mind
um your gender stuff I don't mind
talking about anything and they're like
hang on you're the enemy shut up and I'm
like no
[Music]
as well Lawrence to be fair it's some of
the language that you use in the tweets
where you go I know what he's saying I
agree with what he's saying but this
could be done in a in a manner that is
less inflammatory
yeah but you want the conversation I
want the guy I mean I don't want the
conversation I want other people to have
the conversation you know that's what I
want to have so I I mean give me a tweet
and I'll and I'll explain it to you
right okay we don't do this like we're
not you know we're not the mainstream
media we didn't come in here
yeah I know but I I think you probably
know what we mean though right yeah yeah
100 but I do that deliberately but that
that but this is why I'm not sitting
here in France yeah or Lawrence fox says
you know
you you do it deliberately and we're
trying to understand the strategy I
suppose well I think the strategy is you
get you immediately attract the huge
amount of Interest into what you're
saying yeah and people start debating
each other very hard over a certain
issue and also what you're doing is
you'll as I said you're holding a line
so you're saying instead of going I want
to have a conversation about whether I
think it's all right for to transition
children it's like it's evil and satanic
that's what I so I just go I might as
well why why dither around get to the
point and just say it um I do think that
there are some you know the I've
probably tweeted about 10 times tweets
that I've regretted but
um you know because I could have I don't
regret the point I was trying to make it
just forget the way I expressed it but
um you know Twitter's Twitter that's
what it is it's a sort of Fantasyland of
mad people it doesn't bring out the best
than anyone well and I suppose I was I
was interested to know whether there was
an effect of the fact that the amount of
abuse you get
then sort of transmogrifies its way into
the amount of the way you present you
know because if you're if you are under
that level of sustained assault you you
like get your maces out and your
nunchucks and you're wearing them around
you're your word weapons to go back at
them because you just go I am
impregnable
which is hard because human beings
aren't impregnable you know we're all we
all have feelings even if you're an
alright fascist nazi like me you know we
still we still have feelings so I had to
explain this to a woman the other day
who I was interviewing myself for their
GB and she sat down and she just
character assassinated me and um you
know and she got the point where she was
saying
um that my mother was a coward and my
mum's dead she just died two years ago
and I and after about 15 minutes of it
and my hand was just going I just had to
stand up and I just had to go no one has
upset me that much in years I'm a human
being you have no right to speak to me
like that you've you've you've no
argument to make if you can't remember
that the person you're speaking to is a
human being so I suppose Twitter is not
really you're not speaking to human
beings you're broadcasting it's a sort
of you know I broadcast it's a broadcast
medium for me you were also saying in
your Twitter yesterday you were saying
um not that I obsessively started that
weirdly it's good to know someone reads
it
Elon Musk took over yours now appears in
my feed which you never did before and
you were saying I want to engage with
people then I miss it and as you're
following Grace it's very difficult you
just can't and I really miss a man
because the thing about Twitter is it
gives people like all of us an
opportunity to connect with that person
on the street who's walking along and
doing whatever but once you get to a
point where your audience is big enough
you you've acquired so many hate
followers it's you end up having to sift
through all of it and as you change and
this is why I uh I am pushing myself to
to try and be more as and I'm not
denigrating another approach but to be
more quote unquote constructive in the
way that I conceive of it because I can
see in my own brain the Temptation which
is I get a lot of hate I I can I can I I
look I'm smart and I can be cutting and
funny and whatever I can I can make fun
of people and I can destroy them but I I
don't want to follow that instinct for
me more than anything yeah you see what
I'm saying yeah and that's why I've
that's why we're having this
conversation with you and that's why
we've we're having this uh argument with
Matt Walsh
because I'm trying to work out what the
Right Way Forward is it's not like I've
come in and gone Lawrence Fox must do
this or Matt Walsh must do this just got
questions well the interesting to say is
that there is an interesting thing I was
I would have said it at the end but we
might as well say it now that they're on
our side that's not our side this is the
whole problem you know we've got to be
in human Humanity's side but on the side
of of
loving and respecting people as
individuals you have to also allow them
that peace to go about their business
Matt Walsh if if that's his position on
transgenderism it's it's very entrenched
you will kind of have to go okay because
what happens if you don't I mean I'm not
saying that you guys see this I'm saying
that a lot of people do do this is you
develop what the what I would say is the
right wing version of what wokery is
which is the same sense of moral probity
and Purity and demands for absolute
consistency and adherence to a certain
set of values and ideals so I am that
does sort of weigh in my head as well to
go you know you don't want to be guilty
of
you know attacking other people because
they're not quite
adhering to your version of how one
shouldn't shouldn't communicate I would
say on the freedom of expression side
you need the broadest possible church
and that involves a few um punches if
you met Walsh's who I don't agree with
about a lot of things but I agree with
him on some of the Sounder stuff that he
says and it involves you know the more
the more reason I mean even Lex Friedman
who doesn't really sort of and Joe Rogan
those sort of people who just sort of
are reaching out for information and I
suppose what you guys do because you've
spoken so much to so many people is you
naturally are absorbing and storing a
great amount of information and energy
from the people that you speak to and
you and you know so you're probably in a
stage of evolution that one would one
gets to when one listens to a multitude
of opinions and stuff like that I think
part of the problem as well with Twitter
is because it's text based you remove 90
of communication because it's literally
just reading something and when people
talk about you to me they're like he's
this he's out and I'm like he's none of
those things yeah but you just go on
Twitter it's not a nice guy at all
right
and they just showed that like and they
talk about Twitter but the problem is
you remove 90 of the communication now
as a person you're very warm yeah you're
very open you're very playful those
those are some of the best qualities
that you a human being can have in my
opinion I love watching you on GB news
where you bring on a person who should
we just say is World Cup Progressive or
whatever you want to say and you have a
discussion with them I find those
interviews riveting every time they come
out I will sit down and watch it because
I think they're genuinely brilliant yeah
I love those I I say to the GB news
people never get me on someone I agree
with yeah because I'm only interested in
people I don't agree with yeah and it's
brilliant and you're you're fantastic
with them the the thing that sometimes
when you see the Twitter aspect I don't
think it represents who you are as a
person if I'm honest it doesn't marry
the Lawrence that I know with this
digital Avatar should we just say I
think that is my issue with it because
people do say that about me as well
I think it's you fair enough I suppose I
wonder if I you know I I reckon there's
probably an element of the actor yeah in
the performance you guys go Twitter is
like your little stage where you sort of
perform so you know you've put on a you
put on your armor and you go out there
and you deal with it yeah it is
interesting you're not the only people
that say this to me yeah it's about
complicated from my brother once in a
while he's like he just found something
he I get what's up in the morning and he
goes really
[Music]
really yeah so yeah you know I think
yeah but also bear in mind that I'm
quite uh uh substantial and dramatic
shift in life you know and I'm just
coming to terms with what it is that I
want to achieve it takes time so Twitter
for me is battering ram to work out just
to go right I these are the places that
need defending this is a major major
problem you know see if you get there
though and it also I'm sort of a
counterbalance to the fact that if you
turn on mainstream media they're
constantly inviting the same people on
all the time right so you'll have
Yasmine Alibi Brown who called me a
racist on television right television
you know and I'm like what where's your
evidence of this and then you know the
once that lady Dr Shola who's sitting
there going right baftas it's all white
white and it's just like calm down
darling so I just take the piss at them
yeah by putting up a picture the African
Oscars and going there's a huge lack of
diversity
and you know but it's hit and miss
a funny story when do you remember when
I turned out that contract so many years
ago uh she was on a show to discuss this
and she said oh yeah I've seen this
comedian and it's really not very nice
and then and then they played a clip of
my stand-up and they just cut to her
going oh that was quite funny actually
she's never seen any of my stuff but she
was quite happy to to say stuff you know
one of the interesting points you bring
up which I don't agree with and I think
it's actually important for us ourselves
and for everyone watching to remember is
every person is going through some kind
of process you know and uh we're all on
some kind of Journey like you didn't you
didn't you know you didn't plan to be
here five years ago and neither did we
frankly you know so we're all constantly
trying to work out and by the way all of
this stuff is like when I was how many
of us got educated at University about
like transgenderism yeah you know I mean
like I did do a drama well
even it rather they didn't yeah yeah no
it was a joke it was never an issue and
suddenly there was like a big societal
issue and we're all supposed to have
exactly the right opinion and if you are
woke you you were supposed to go yes
everyone's transgender and non-binary
and fluid and whatever and increasingly
On The Rise Like You must use this
language and not that language and that
Purity you're talking about were all to
some extent susceptible to it
um and that's why I think conversation
is is important yeah I couldn't agree on
and I as I said I only really want to on
the GB thing because it's you know it's
an hour and you don't really get I just
want people who I who I don't agree with
because I also I'm I'm very open
to being persuaded of the gray area No
Man's Land I will negotiate no man's
land with anybody but what I can't
negotiate is my own border my own
personal border and that is the meaning
of words I don't like words when they're
shifted around and really find it
appalling that you know for all Roald
dahls having his books Rewritten when he
was deliberately trying to wind up kids
and make them rebellious against their
parents by using these sort of quite
extreme you know what nowadays is even
extreme and potentially offensive
language
um and that for me is a border and that
we need borders everybody needs a border
because you know as Muskie said the
other day he said if you've got one
world government with one civilization
and that falls then what's going to
replace it you know civilizations have
to come and civilizations have to have
to go and you know I think we've we've
as you say we have this sort of leaky
border leaky cultural border where
things come into this country which had
never really been an issue and actually
I don't think we're we're you know blood
since last time we spoke I think it's
got infinitely worse and I think I said
last time when we spoke I said it's
gonna get infinitely worse and it's and
it's not even we're not even anywhere
near the peak of it yeah I mean I think
sturgeon was a was a marker in the sand
that even sane people would turn around
and go it's definitely not a good idea
to lock up a rapist with a bunch of
women
probably a bad idea and I think the
backlash to that was was good but I
don't think we've reached Peak you don't
no I mean on the trans thing in the UK
at least it seems like we're making good
progress you know Tavistock being shut
down and investigated and so on but you
don't think this is the transgender
thing is just is just a vector for it
it's not it's never been about
transgender rights or gay and lesbian
rights because otherwise why do you have
to lump them all in together because gay
Everyone's an individual so why do you
have to why why gays and lesbians biceps
and transgender people in a group with a
plus plus on the end of it it's about uh
you know the it's about power and
control the whole thing is it it's about
authoritarian kind of you know communist
socialist style dragging everyone down
to being exactly the same sort of thing
and it just uses these vectors
to work its way into society so it
started off with you know all the meters
and and the racism and black lives
matter and transgenderism and it's going
to move pretty swiftly onto mental
health now which is going to be so
impossible to
um which why I try and talk start to
talk about it a bit more because I think
it's important that we remind everybody
that we're human beings because that's
what's most dangerous
this the the woke thing whatever it is
very difficult to quantify it is going
to go into mental health primarily I'd
imagine and you won't be able to say
anything because of the damage it will
actually physically do to someone's
mental health so you think it's that's
going to become the next Battlefield
where people are going to say you can't
say that I have depression you can't say
that I have depression or what you've
just said has given me depression or has
damaged my brain in some way and has
hurt me in a way which is medical
um
that is obviously unquantifiable because
it's unquantifiable and then then that's
really bad because if you sort of
medicalize it and you're it's actually
doing someone's actual health
uh because they'll make it they'll
they'll you know they'll sort of
cross-pollinate it with your physical
health as well and it'll be like you
just can't say anything because you're
actually really injuring someone I know
they the words are violence thing exists
already but it's it hasn't been properly
that that sit Rich scene of wokeness is
yet to be mined I don't think and you're
talking about a gray area dance what are
the gray areas for you that are up for
debate
um
abortion so I mean is one up for debate
um the consequences of freedom of speech
stuff like
um Can language be violent can language
be hateful all of these sorts of areas
I'm happy to talk about
um what else is a gray area
um
sexual politics I'm happy to be
persuaded about I'm happy to be taught
to talk about privilege I'm I'm not that
interested in talking about skin kind of
privilege because I don't think it's
relevant because I think yeah there are
lots of different privileges
um I'd say that those are sorts let's
talk about privilege because uh to an
outsider and maybe it's objectively true
you are like literally the most
privileged person they've ever seen yeah
on TV you know you're a posh white guy
went to Harrow rather actor you know
from an acting Dynasty blah blah blah
right and that is actual privilege isn't
it real genuine class a privilege that
is yeah it's uncut privilege
um it's yeah absolutely 100 there's a
couple of things that go with it like
one is it's immutable so you have no say
in it because I didn't get anything to
how I was born and B it's a
socio-economic thing and an educational
thing yeah way ahead of the fact that
it's a skin color thing of course you
know so so on that level yeah I'm very
almost one of the one of the reasons why
I do what I do is because I realize how
privileged I am
and you know unless you get into
politics because you want to get into
politics because you want to have power
and control over other people or you
know if you're really interested in
trade deals you want to affect that I'm
only in it to to represent the voice of
Your Average Joe's voice never gets
represented you're Darren Brady who just
goes what are your thoughts on this
Transit entity so yeah I think privilege
is real but also you can the more the
question is what do you do with it like
Jordan Peterson interviewed me recently
and we talked about this which was
privilege exists uh it's different and
it's primarily as you say socioeconomic
particularly in this country and class
based to some extent which is slightly
different but almost the same
um but the question is okay well you're
privileged like what are you supposed to
do jump off a bridge now you know I mean
that's what they want they would like it
yeah yeah but actually you know I mean
this is why the conversation we have
about privilege is so stupid because
rather than once I pretending no one's
ever privileged and neither side
pretending that privilege is given to
you by virtue of pigmentation in your
skin actually you go well people grow up
in different circumstances now what now
what what do we do with this now now
that we've established that different
people don't have the same chance in
life which they never ever in history
have done and never will in the future
ever because it's impossible what do we
do now what do we do with it and I think
part of the answer is you you do
something that you think is constructive
particularly for people who don't have
as much as you or didn't have the same
style in life isn't it and also but we
get we've got genetic privilege oh
absolutely you know some more than
others you're tall and handsome darling
I am you know I've either I I'm a very
very rich friend who got diagnosed with
cancer on his 20th birthday and died 20
years later of in absolute
uncontrollable Agony having lived in
England for 20 years he was minted
really nice house and lovely cars and
everything yeah well done mate but um
his life was not privileged in anyway
whatsoever so privilege is a very subtle
thing and I think
I I'm really you know you're talking
about trying to be constructive I I care
about that bit in the Bible that says
love your enemies I because I think just
as a philosophical and emotional
exercise it is absolutely where your
brain should be how can I find love for
them because if I can love them then I
can listen to them
but at the same time it's very very very
hard when you are being goaded
relentlessly by the other side or not
the other side
it's so difficult but it does feel like
another side yeah of course it does you
know especially someone like me who had
their career just ripped away you know I
ever I was removed was not you know
surgically removed very quickly from
from cult you've had for not having the
right opinions so it does feel like
there is a bit you know these we're
being goaded a lot you know and and it's
it's difficult not to retaliate to that
yeah but we should actually focus more
on trying to love them well this is why
this is why we were having the
conversation about Twitter early because
I suppose from their perspectives they
would say that you are guarding them
yeah and they are reacting to you and
that's why we get into this which I am
which you are yeah because I'm using the
same I'm using exactly the same tool
back at them I'm pointing out the utter
absurdity of what they stand for and how
humbly believably dangerous what they're
playing with is it's extremely dangerous
to do what is being attempted you know
by not even in a democratically elected
way certainly you know what's for being
an example or what they think it said
within schools and you know or
immigration policy nobody voted for the
policies that we currently have exactly
why don't you why can't you just take I
was great and 10 out of the issue and
just you know why doesn't this happen
and you start to realize that actually
this is you know there's an established
this is an establishment which protects
itself and no one's really going to take
these cultural problems on you know
because it's too scared of them but
actually I mean Lee Anderson said that
the Tories will go after the cultural
issues didn't he because he said that
will have to that'll be one of the
things that will get them connected so
even if they do do that the Tories
my job will have been worthwhile because
I would have played some part in that
because you know I've stoked those
culture wars and I've brought them right
to the front of attention and I suppose
if you're asking why why I do it with
such a mallet and that and a baseball
bat because I don't think there's that
much time
for this to to stop it we polled the
other day a load of teachers oh sorry
load of parents about what their kids
are being taught in school so we we gave
them options about what being taught in
school and 70 of the parents of this
generation 39 to 54 or whatever it is
would app absolutely against
what was being taught to their kids in
school certainly in regards to die and
gender Radiology skin color privilege
that sort of thing they were potentially
against it but the generation down
50 then think it's brilliant idea
so 50 of them want socialism that's what
they want they're Keen for it they want
the state to be in charge they want they
don't want any personal autonomy you
know and that's worrying so you know
that's why I say look there's there's a
war on the suppression of free
expression which is what which is where
democracy dies anyway and you need in
that war you're going to need you know
idiots like me who jump out the trench
and go whirling towards the enemies
so that the generals couldn't careful
strategists can go right well let's not
attack from that side next time
it's an interesting matter yeah yeah so
uh we were talking about freedom of
expression and GB news
um have come under Fire particularly
with the case of Mark Stein you had a
very interesting point of view on it
what was it it was one of the few times
I was sensible
um I think that I mean I think ofcom as
an idea uh again actually what you asked
me a question let me assume that people
don't know what happened anyway my time
was uh offered a contract for uh that
said because he said he's he's a
supplier to the channel he's not an
employee so they said right if you're a
surprised Channel and you mess up and
you get fined by ofcom because you
misread a bit of data or you don't
represent the other side of the argument
or whatever you're going to be liable
for those fines that was a negotiation
number one Stephen Crowder did the same
thing with the daily wire it's like
don't publicize contract negotiations
straight away I think that's a slightly
crass thing to do and it's it's a sign
of weakness they did treat him
appallingly in my view uh based on the
fact that he had just had two heart
attacks and it was really bad anyway my
take on it is you should have the other
side of the argument if offcome demand
that you have the other side of the
argument that's good an off-commer going
after this Paul you know ITV and BBC who
after this poor is it Nicola bully yes
so I don't think ofcom I think of com
are the enemy but I think I I if we care
about free expression and we we should
absolutely represent the other side in
in debate and Mark made to
uh had two problems with ofcom and GB
news I can understand it if they're
going to be fire uh find a percentage of
their annual turnover when they've
already got hope not hey campaigning 24
hours a day to stop them getting any
advertisers then I think that you know
Mark should go should have maybe just
held his hands up and said okay let's
negotiate this contract and I for that I
was vilified but by the right wing
wokists who demand absolute moral
property and you if you don't agree with
us on vaccines on this on this and it's
like you're playing into their hands
guys the one thing that we celebrate is
our is the fact that all of us are
different and and that we encourage that
it also means that we can not anymore
get in line yeah but it's it's exactly
it's what happens it's you know history
is replete with this stuff so
um yeah everyone got very upset with me
about that but I stand by it I think you
know I think my is a great broadcaster I
think he made it he misread some data on
TV and it will have affected people's
lives that's why I stay the hell away
from data because I don't know you know
I don't do data you give me you know an
easy salmon I would get in trouble with
it so you know if you chose to do it
they defended him but they're
renegotiating his contract they'll be
right
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
Lawrence do you think also that's such a
good point about the data aspect of it
because I see a lot of commentators and
basically this is not gbus this is
commentators across the board they'll go
on to talk about one week they'll talk
about vaccines the next week they'll
talk about Ukraine the next week they're
talking about NHS then they're talking
about the migrant crisis and the week
after that the economy and I'm like
either you are some Next Level genius
who has a fundamental understanding of
each of these subjects brought about by
years of discipline intellectual rigor
and study or more likely
oh well actually you're you're
Christians yeah yeah and don't you think
that is the problem as well yeah and
also I think it's a circular thing so
your list of things that they go and
talk about and then they start getting
the next Monday yeah which is a real
shame yeah no I think one must operate
from a from a position of you know
Occam's razor is probably quite a good
start with these things and then yeah
stay away from data leave data because
data is easy everyone's got a bit of
data I I adopt always just I I sort of
adopted which is can get me into trouble
the gun to the Head philosophy it's like
yes or no Bill Gates yes or no no
um you know pandemic is it going to kill
000 people no you know it's just I just
I I kind of just I operate on an
instinct and my instincts are quite
simple and it's confined to only a few
areas really so I don't go out there and
try and bombard people with data the
only data I'm actually interested in at
the moment out of all the data is the
excess deaths data that does interest me
because I'm like hang on a minute
um if there's that many excess deaths
now and there were that many excess
deaths during what was referred to as a
pandemic then if we'd never declared a
pandemic
would there ever been a pandemic do you
know what I mean so I am interested in
it on a on a sort of philosophical level
I might they decayed a pandemic but now
we've got a load of excess deaths now I
wouldn't go into going talk back to your
Norms it's all this sorts because I
don't know but I would go that's quite
interesting and also why is anyone
talking about it I think that's such a
profound point the fact that ain't no
one's talking about it but yet as well
there are people on both left that well
they're not left and right the people on
both sides of the arguments who purport
to know what is actually going on when
you talk to people who actually
understand this they're scientists
they're doctors they're epidemiologists
whatever and they will the people
actually know will go we don't know
multifaceted hugely like everything it's
hugely multifaceted and everything
affects everything else it's why it's
sort of easy just to fall back and go
what what do I I have instincts and I
believe that those instincts have got me
into all the trouble I've ever gone to
never listen to them again
you know but I guess what we're talking
about this is one of the reasons I
generally don't do panel shows anymore
because you're going to get asked
questions about things you don't
understand and that you are in front of
a camera having to you know pretend to
have an opinion about this stuff and I
found that it forced me to have opinions
about things I don't have an opinion
about and it's just so those instincts
we actually I mean uh Brett Brett
Weinstein I had a discussion about this
a long time ago which is like how do you
know what you think you know and when it
comes to something like the pandemic or
covert or vaccines or whatever is
basically you listen to certain people
whom you trust why you trust them is
very do you see what I'm saying I do
anyway that actually I remember getting
called by a journalist before they uh it
was public knowledge so you know what
was going to happen in terms of covered
and probably a week before it was
announced and they said this is what's
going on even before the first lockdown
no no before it was even an issue they a
journalist who I knew well foamy and
said
is coming for UK it's a mega killer well
like in January 2020 yeah yeah and um I
I just said no it's not it's it's not
it's not gonna be that bad that's what I
said I said it's just a just a bit of
flu it turns out I was quite wrong yeah
but it will you know I don't know it's
so I think there's what you know how do
you know what you know I think a lot of
it's experience so for example I
realized the other day that I can't
watch films that don't start with a man
asleep on a band with a bottle of
whiskey next to him who wakes up
coughing lights a cigarette gets a call
from his divorce wife who says that he
owes her anime and then he goes and
Saves the World those are the only films
I can watch and the Bruce Willis or
Denzel Washington needs to be in there
you're going to save the world and you
know everything bad that could possibly
happen is that why you're a big fan of
Hunter Biden Lawrence
oh I'm not a fan of his yeah I've only
just got my voice back actually from
that fake crack yeah and it's still yeah
still that really didn't know I lost a
stone in weight did you enjoy having a
stint of acting back was was that I
loved it but I didn't allow myself to
enjoy it too much because I knew it was
a fleeting fancy and a sabbatical away
from the cancellation and you really
can't go back to acting well I'd love to
I I don't mean like I don't mean that as
in you're not capable I think you know
yeah yeah no I'd love to no one would
have it no I don't know acting is like
you know if you if you're talking about
the uh The Crucible of all of this
inclusivity acting's where it's at you
know it's right it's it's the it's you
know you're never going to break that
apart and let me ask you a question on
that because one of the things we found
you know when we started trigonometry
two comedians on the British comedy
circuit uh we were instantly evil you
know right wing all this other stuff
that's just not true about us
it's been five years
and we started to get messages now from
the very people that used to have a go
and I was going you know what
I didn't agree with you but and you know
sort of do you not get those messages
from actors and directors going you know
what yeah yeah I didn't quite agree but
there's something to this whole is that
not happening oh yeah a lot of messages
from actually saying I agree with
everything you say right but I'm never
ever going to tell anyone I do
so yeah the you know the percent ship in
show businesses it's well it's one
another one of the reasons why I go yeah
would I love to go back to acting yeah
but would I like to stand on set going I
can't say anything
[Music]
shouldn't be running alongside culture
art should be smacking it on that you
know that I think that's absolutely
where am I at where my attitude comes
from which is the art is meant to expose
the Ridiculousness of their current
culture and it's actually one of the
greatest weapons to stop you know mono
monoculturism and you know sort of this
cultural Marxism infecting us all so
it's one of those things where you more
can ridicule it or you you carefully
attack it you know brilliant playwrights
have done throughout the years so um
it's a shame actually I mean bar a few
exceptions that are it's just done some
of the same train track just five feet
to the side going we're against the
culture well that art is actually
running in front of the train yeah it is
well whiteness has to run in front of
the train because you know look look at
them you unless you're the fastest
Sprinter towards the uh Utopia of woken
it's it's game over Stephen Fry poor
poor Sarge yeah he's got he's got in the
[__] for actually so yeah so um we were
going to talk about it on our raw show
so basically he did a I think it was a
charity dinner or something like that
for the MCC the cricket I'm not Posh
enough to know basically the cricket
Lawrence come on tell us about the
cricket he did um he did this he did a
speech he made a joke you know obviously
you want to do is to get paid he made a
joke about women he said business you
know and I think it was actually Pro
women yeah which was weird because
someone again the Jordan what was the
job the joke was something like there
are no women here because they're all
off shagging no no no it was so so okay
look it's lovely to be here there's no
women here so let's talk about shagging
right exactly there you go you're
getting canceled for that no he then
there's a cricket team which is called
the uh abracadabras or something like
that or he had a complicated game and he
called it the aliwack parse anyway
someone complained and you know the
Jordan Peterson thing happened you know
if you talk to a room full of 10 people
someone's going to be offended but um I
think EMCC had pushed back I sense that
they push back but Stephen Fry will now
have that little taint on his hand that
is difficult to remove and you know if
you're not running far ahead of them
with your new latest idea
um you'll never be pure enough for them
no but we've got to stop it on the other
side of the argument I couldn't agree
with him more because I'm this is why uh
perhaps sometimes I can be oversensitive
to people who are anti-woke going
slightly in my opinion off the deep end
because I worry about that part of
becoming you know you there there is
many ways that the right is becoming the
wokified in the same way because as we
talked about you know when you stare
into the abyss the best stares into you
and we adopt the same tactics and the
same Purity Spirals and and to some
extent you could say we're guilty of it
but also people are like you must use
the right pronouns well there are some
trans people who say I'd like to be
called she and I like that person and
I'll call the machine fine but well you
say fine there's a bunch of people
online no you are now canceled but I I
also understand their arguments and I
support their argument so because if you
go well if you stay she and you
acknowledge transgenderism what's next
so I get what they're trying to do
that's their board but I still have the
right to choose my words 100 and the
reason I'm sitting in this chair five
years from starting trigonometry is at
one point I said no no [__] you I'm not
letting you the work comedy industry
tell me what I should say and think 100
and I'm gonna be like that with the left
right up down whatever people like us
should have the ability to choose their
own words and think for themselves and
people can argue and criticize and
whatever but I'm never going to have
people telling me what to think or what
to do which is exactly the right way to
do and we must that is one of the ways
that we love one another is we say you
have that right and we protect it for
other people and you know we and
ultimately you protect it for the for
the horrible people that's who you're
protecting it for most weirdly for the
people you hate and not hate the people
that you you just you cannot connect
with or find any common ground with you
have to protect them it's your job it's
loving them and it's really hard and I
just I don't think I think it's probably
a lifetime's work and more which is why
it exists this idea you know and it just
sticks out every morning I wake up and I
think love your enemies
what
how but then you see someone suffer
someone you'd really don't agree with
suffering you start to feel a sense of
real compassion and you know even a
warming sense of love like I'd hate to
see someone who's any of the people that
have tried to have me canceled I'd hate
to see any of them suffer yeah I really
wouldn't so you know when you were
asking about how I am I think
fundamentally how I am is good I think
the the building blocks of my nature and
my personality are strong and really
good but I think I'm very sensitive and
I think people don't understand I am and
I probably don't do myself on Twitter by
going you know I'm not sensitive at all
yeah so yeah I think we need that's
where the the ground will be is when we
can get to the point of going I love you
no matter as long as you're not trying
to kill anybody
you know I love you yes I will support
you it comes back to Christ on the cross
forgive them Lord for they know not what
they do I think so I mean it's not a bad
even if you don't believe in God and
you're out of Faith it's not a bad
manual for living no Proverbs and all
that and all this sort of stuff it's not
a bad thing this idea that somebody else
has died so that you can be a bastard to
everybody you know and it's this modern
infection of going you know I mean a lot
of people who go I'm just I'm just a
really good person you know I know I'm a
good person I'm like you're [__]
deluded if you think you're a good
person because if you if I started
spouting half the [__] that went on in
my head and just things that people say
to you you know you're not a good person
that's why you've got to talk all the
time and you've got to express you've
got to connect with people because
you've got to find how you can be a
better person from the you know lovely
made in the image of Christ that you are
but the fundamentally pretty simple
creature that we all are as well I think
that's why the see this is I've been
thinking about this a lot
I don't oppose wokeness even as much
because of the ideology as I do because
of the tactics right because if a work
person came on TV and said you know what
I believe in in sectionality and
transgenderism and all of the stuff and
I could say well I don't let's have a
discussion about this I have absolutely
no problem with that conversation
happening what I have a problem with is
being made to be evil and a bad person
and having my life destroyed and people
who are not in the position of having a
big YouTube channel or whatever having
their lives destroyed for wanting to
challenge those ideas it's the tactics
that bother me as much as the ideology
and look people can people have always
disagreed about politics right there
will always be the the people who are
more Progressive and they want change
for the sake of change or they believe
change is good in and of itself and
there are people who who think that's
less wise to an approach and that's
because people are born with different
personality types and their life
experiences are different that will
always happen but the 10 tactics that
we've got to position now where it's
like you disagree with me
what the [__] is wrong with you you're
an evil person that's what bothers me
and that's why I am very sensitive to
same things happening on the right or
the anti-worker wherever it is because I
see the same tactics now starting to be
used and that I think should worry us
actually well I couldn't agree with you
more because there's a there's an
appetite for Revenge yes when those
tactics are used yes so I suppose what
I've I've been trying to do is
think about what wokeness is and how
what's good about it
and it's really interesting as a Thor
exercise because I haven't really done
that I haven't had time today I've been
too busy doing my great tweets right
and you know I've
of course you want to be more you want
to include people more and and you and
you know especially the most vulnerable
in society but as you say that that's
that may be their agenda deep down what
what drives them as a human being just
as valuable and important as you and I
but those tactics as you say us are
they're either disingenuous they're
intellectually corrupt as well a lot of
their the ways that they do things and B
they use the the tactics that they use a
tactics you tend not to find being used
up till this point that as we're saying
you get a bit more worried you know that
Matt Walsh video which I saw again this
morning when he says what he says about
what he would do to someone who came
near his children that is
you know that you only have to he's got
a huge following that guy you know and
it only takes one we'll play the movie
Forward yeah do you know moving forward
that's the worry yeah that's the worry
so we we gotta we we have to just reach
across to those that can be reached
across too yes and then we'll leave the
extremes on either side to cancel each
other out
that's what I think they will do they
will just cancel each other out but we
can't we can't have culture revolving
and and you know Society revolving
around one of these or either of these
extremes at the same time so everyone in
the middle is homeless which is what
we've you know you guys started doing
this for which was to have interesting
honest conversations with interesting
people which leads to which is why
people care about what you do because
you're not picking aside and absolutely
Lawrence says because I love talking to
you about culture and ER and you did a
film uh which is my son Hunter with the
daily Wire yeah
I did it with them I did it with it
Breitbart released it oh Breitbart
released it now you've got what is
starting to happen in the culture which
is inevitable really where you've got
Progressive where mainstream art is
Progressive
left-wing work whatever you want to call
it and now you've got this other so
you've got art which is starting to be
produced by the daily wire
Etc
where do you think this goes is this a
positive thing to have art which is
expressly left or right
and is there something that we can do to
kind of maybe have our which is
apolitical which is what I think is
better I'm just interested to hear your
point of view I think it's I I I I I
think that we didn't notice how
political art was you know I didn't
notice so you know if you look at the
films made during the Reagan Era they're
very one sort of type of film you know
and you look at the films made when I
was growing up you know Bruce Willis
lying drunk on the bed gets up and has
saved the world it's sort of it imprints
in you I think that with the incredible
rise in technology you we're going to
see films made for a lot less money
ultimate you know you've got that
amazing little Gizmo there which you
know on a film set I was there when the
first slider turned up on a film set and
everyone was like and then you can buy
one off Amazon you know so I think we're
going to see lots more films made I I
think what would be and weirdly the
Hollywood bubble will become just more
of a bubble where money is spent on
films that not many people watch and
they all give each other a round of
applause so their nature balls a vacuum
and there will be films that come along
I've someone sent me a script the other
day but we're still in the early stages
of the of the um other part of culture
because and they're all about like I
think the film about the vaccine okay
[Music]
it will need to catch up but it I think
it's great that you have you know in the
same way as we're gonna have problems
with money yeah aren't we it's going to
vanish we're going to have the the black
market will start to get bigger won't it
and you know people will start trading
in different ways I think culturally
what we'll see is a
I think Hollywood is funded by the
Chinese anyway so they're never going to
run our money along with Sport and all
of these things so we will we will see a
rise in independent filmmaking there are
some good independent films advantages
have been assume was a great movie I
really enjoyed it so yeah
you cannot kill art you can't but you
also you Hollywood is just gonna be I
think it's just I fund it it's very
relevant
utterly irrelevant you know I mean
someone won an award what's the name
Kate Blanchett won an award for a film
called tar I'm never going to watch this
film and she went you know it's I it's I
find it's empowering women and it's
great and I was like I was in the film
with you where you played Queen
Elizabeth the first I mean is there a
better part
why are you going all about empowering
women you've had the best sorting career
ever why can't you just go thank you and
move on instead of having to politicize
it about you know women in some way it's
boring so do you think Hollywood is
ultimately doomed I think Hollywood no
because Hollywood's Hollywood you know
there's always going to be the the say
like the same people that go to the
National Theater and I mean I don't know
I'm unfamiliar with how they're going to
do the production of our families The
Crucible but I'm
fairly confident they will cross-cast it
with the women will be the men and the
men will be witches and they won't be a
single white person in it so there will
be there will always be an audience you
know that sort of great full National
theater audience in the same age you'll
get a grateful Hollywood audience to go
me and my highfalutin
um cultural experience and intelligence
and you know gentle taste buds for
fabulous culture we'll just carry on
uploading it like clapping seals
uploading an iceberg but surely when the
accountants come in they are businesses
and they go look this is a revenue from
the latest film
Disney though how much did Disney lose
what was it full I don't know what
exactly it's it's in the billions they
lost last year really in the billions
and they're still pumping out all of
that you know woke kids shows I saw one
the other day it's the worst thing about
Twitter isn't it also the thing about
Twitter is it completely deprives
everyone of context so but I saw a scene
which was actually long enough for this
little kid show where it's sitting there
going you only got the prince because
you were white and it's like
okay so Disney not has lost a lot of
money I bet China pays for it all
doesn't it you know that's why you don't
get any Chinese villains in anything
anymore it's all Russian villains now
you don't get any challenge so China is
subsidizing
what do you reckon I need to ask you
about this because I was reading your
pushing thing and I because that's one
of the other things I sort of try and
stay out of a bit is the Ukraine
situation because I know all about
geopolitics I understand I understand
probably more than someone who knows
nothing but I don't understand it
seriously why when I was reading through
what person was saying and I was
watching what he was saying he was
really going at the culture wasn't he
the wet so he's talking to yeah so he's
trying to talk talk with just explain it
to me what what well there is a growing
and as I think all three of us would
agree fairly Justified anti-elite
sentiment in the West
um and he recognizes that that is a
process that's going on in the west and
if you can speak to the people who are
anti the elite and the West that means
that he can secure support in the West
for whatever it is that he's doing or
against whatever is the elites are doing
uh I think that's that's it's literally
that it's just a clever pay I was just
interesting I was like why is he going
after wokeness and culture so I thought
out of all the things you could go I
mean I I don't think he's all that
concerned about transgender clinic in
Ohio or whatever it is that that's
really not what or the the Anglican
Church doing very stupid things as the
Anglican Church is doing but yeah that
there isn't really his primary but he's
so he's finding it he's he's sort of
like all successful people he's trying
to find the theme with which he can
crack the rock exactly of Western
resistance yeah I think that's it that's
and uh of all the criticisms that people
can make of Vladimir Putin he's not a
stupid man uh I have many criticisms of
the things that he's doing of course but
uh he's very smart yeah and and the
other thing is he's uh this is the
weakness of democracy uh for all its
many uh huge benefits and achievements
uh we have short-term leaders who have
short-term thinking yeah Vladimir Putin
has been in power since 1999.
24 years she'll probably be in power for
another eight years at least right so
that that is a period of time when you
can consolidate power
you can get rid of anyone who's a
problem uh in in various ways it doesn't
have to be violent but you can you can
make sure that they're not in the room
um and then you can implement the agenda
that you think uh and that means that
you can simply you know that Chinese
saying the best strategy and war is to
sit by the river and wait for the bodies
of the enemies to float by you can do
that if you've got 30 years if you're
less trust and you've got 44 days
yeah probably not so that's a huge
Advantage I mean
we've got to a point in the west where I
think we uh we think that
uh like the values that we have are
perfect you know democracy tolerance
like and they have no trade-offs not
really that that isn't true there are no
Solutions there are only trade officers
my favorite Thomas orqua and so dictate
the ship on authoritarianism has huge
advantages when it comes to situations
like the ones that we find ourselves in
now and this is why quite often when
countries go to war they in in in the
Roman Empire for example they were quite
often not have democracy or not have the
system of government that they would
have during wartime and they would
appoint someone who was essentially a
dictator to take them through that
um and so in times like these strong
leadership has massive advantages yeah
that's that's really interesting and
also the comment about which if your
enemies to float by because another
thing that is that I am learning and I
was fortunately told it by a wise man
who I because I started to consult wise
men now because I think it's probably a
good idea
um and he said sometimes best thing to
do is just sit in your hands and do
nothing that's hard for Young People
Like Us youngish well yeah because I
feel also I feel guilt you know work
guilt usually like we've got to do
something what are we going to do and I
was speaking to this guy and he said
something it was just you know the fight
comes to you man it's not like you're
running around the playground looking
for people to punch they come all come
there's a cure them lining up to punch
you in the face so you don't need to
stop you don't need to chase the fight
you need to you know and that's I think
actually one of the good things so if
he's I'm I've not even if I enjoyed
talking but I've also it is a it is a
it's a thought I will take away because
it's like
you don't need to be on a wall footing
all the time certainly not for Corso
levels and stress levels within you but
you get quite used to them yeah so when
you get when you get a go on summer
holiday or something and it's like what
we can do today have a few beers and go
water skiing it's like yeah but but how
are we going to change the way water
skiing is done so it's like yeah that's
what I mean about the process you know
it's early in my sort of understanding
about what I'm meant to be here to do
yeah which is sort of a question that
we've should all ask ourselves all the
time yeah and the problem is is when you
start fusing conflict with your identity
and that's the moment you get into
somewhere dark because you start
thinking well what I am here to do is to
do X and all of a sudden when X isn't
available
then what is yeah and what are you faced
with and then you realize that actually
you're what you're doing is
externalizing
what is inside
and until you face what's inside
you're never going to be able to solve
the external and yeah which is true and
it's also like the you know exactly it's
still the French Revolution thing if
once you start chopping people's heads
off
in order for the French Revolution to
continue and the terror we have chopped
some more people's heads off yeah you
know it's sort of self-perpetuating yeah
I think it's right but also there is the
the counter argument to that is is
defense rather than attack you know it's
The Shield versus the Sword which one is
which one is more useful but both are
required well I think it's something
that all of us are trying to navigate so
it's been a pleasure having you back
Lawrence and talking about all of this
uh before we ask uh questions from our
supporters that only they will get to
see the answers to on locals that
they've already submitted uh we've got
one final question for you which is
always the same uh what is the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be well we just talked about it
for ages
uh the worrying rise in right wing
so-called right-wing workery and loving
our enemies
amen uh Lawrence Fox thanks for coming
back on the show and uh guys thank you
for watching and listening we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7 pm UK time and for
those of you who like your trigonometry
on the go it is always available as a
podcast take care and see you soon guys
ask Lawrence if Madonna was batshit
mental when he worked with her on the
film we
oh my Lord
yeah really yeah so
[Music]